I want to give you the time to set the
record straight about your marriage what
happened and where you stand today with
your husband okay
so my husband and I met him in 2004 got
married had a baby in 2006 I was married
to him for a while in San Francisco
didn't like San Francisco had kind of um
you know problems in the marriage
let me move so I moved out here Michael
was going back and forth and then you
know we weren't relationship it's just
kind of you know going you know you know
like this so I filed for legal
separation and I met this other guy got
engaged got to means filed for divorce
and then me and the other guy didn't
work out I went back to my husband
stayed with my husband this was three
years ago
we have a pretty good marriage now I
mean we have no ups and downs like
everybody right but in every
relationship if you're with somebody
constantly yes you're gonna have some
kind of problems yes we try to deal with
our problems head-on and we're still
together you know for we're happy I mean
as happy it can be in those days where I
wanted to I miss him
or I wish you die oh yeah I just I don't
know better he write this about me a
better place than you were five years
ago
Oh much much better place he realizes
it's cheaper to keep her and then IRA
and I realize you know um if you're with
what people might as well be with your
husband with a kid the one you yeah the
one you know so but you're in love with
your husband
he's a really nice person you're not
answering the question Kelly do you love
him or not I do say yes but we didn't
see it we didn't see it
I said yes so you do love your husband I
do love my husband before we got married
Michael was perfect and then when we got
married he became like Hitler
he was control freak relationships take
work and and you know I don't want to
get divorced I want to stick with him
and want to I want my family together I
don't there's so many more negatives
about separating than there are to stay
together and it takes work you know yeah
that's not easy I just hope for the best
I hope that we stay together I don't
want to get divorced